record
this week on book notes our guest is
Speaker of the House Denny Hastert he
joins us to discuss his book speaker
lessons from 40 years of coaching and
politics Denny Hastert author of speaker
what's the Granby role Graeme roll is a
move in wrestling that you can score
from the bottom not many people do it
and it's good and rustling it's probably
good in politics too if you can score
when you're on the bottom and keep
winning that's what it's all about
where's the name Granby come on Granby
high school in Norfolk Virginia
they were the instigator a coach by the
name of Bill Martin was instigated it
and taught it and kind of passed through
the East Coast I picked it up in a
Midwest and was one of our trademarks
when was the last time you were in a
high school classroom teaching I
probably was about a year or two ago I
try to go back to my district and talk
in a classroom from time to time
actually teaching as a teacher the last
time we did it was 1981 and what were
you teaching I was teaching economics
history government I taught a business
course over the years I taught a speech
course and in a small high school you
did everything I even drove the school
bus from time to time where's this
picture from went on Garfield High
School how old were you there I was
probably twenty four years old I'm gonna
jump way ahead and show you a clip and
I'll have you first if it's a clip of
Bob Livingston on the floor just so when
people are watching it they'll know
where were you in the chamber at that
time I was sitting in the back row of
the chamber right near the door where
folks come in off the elevator that's
where I use I was chief deputy whip
that's usually where I sat and I kind of
knew where everybody was and on the
House floor that was kind of my position
what was the time frame well the time
frame was December 19th there was a
Saturday we
back because of impeachment of Bill
Clinton was the house vote on the floor
I remember getting up that morning and
thinking to myself you know I taught
history for years and we went through
the impeachment of Andrew Johnson and it
changed presidential history for years
and I'm thinking what's going to happen
after we get done with this vote today
House history going to change all that I
know that what would happen so when Bob
Livingston began to talk you did not
know what was going to happen well we
knew that Bob had some problems but we
didn't know what was going to happen
let's watch the tape and we'll ask you
about it to the president I would say
sir you have done great damage to this
nation over this past year and while
your defenders are contending that
further impeachment proceedings would
only protract and exacerbate the damage
to this country I say that you have the
power to terminate that damage and heal
the wounds that you have created you sir
may resign your post
house will be in order
and and
the house will be in order
and I can only challenge you in such
fashion if I am willing to heed my own
words to my colleagues my friends and
most especially my wife and family I
have hurt you all deeply and I beg your
forgiveness I was prepared to lead our
narrow majority as Speaker and I believe
I had it in me to do a fine job but I
cannot do that job or be the kind of
leader that I would like to be under
current circumstances so I must set the
example that I hope President Clinton
will follow I will not stand for Speaker
of the House on January 6th but rather I
shall remain as a backbencher in this
Congress that I so dearly love for
approximately six months into the
hundred and sixty Congress whereupon I
shall vacate my seat and ask my governor
to call a special election to take my
place what was going through your head
well it was we're kind of stunned about
the halfway after he had made its
announcement there was a page that came
up or one of our floor blows and page
one over four people came up to have me
and on his shoulder I was in the back
row and said the speaker wants to talk
to you he's on the phone in the
cloakroom who was Speaker it was Newt
Gingrich and I went to the phone Newt
says you just heard what happened you're
the only guy that can pull this
conference together and lead it and I
was kind of dumbstruck at that point
yeah then people can start to come up to
me I said you're going to be the next
speaker and for somebody who hadn't
planned on you know being a speaker of
the house and just doing his work as a
backbencher that was a really an
astounding situation he said you called
your wife at some point right
I called Jeanne after people said you
know you're gonna be the speaker and
said I'll give me a couple minutes to
think about this I need to talk to my
wife
bill paxton who was a good friend of
mine
anticipate as when I said he called my
wife first and said you know Dan he's
going to have to do this and you know so
I called her I thought Jean would say
she doesn't live in Washington we didn't
keep our home in Washington she didn't
necessarily want to get involved and
everything she was teaching school at
the time and I would think I would
thought that she would say well you know
just for our life we can't really can't
do this and so I called it was the first
day of Christmas vacation and I I was
anticipating she was home its first day
home that was a Saturday morning and I
called her episode what are you doing
and I thought if I'm baking cookies or
fixing a tree or doing something like
that and she's well I'm watching TV that
said well you know what's going on here
and she said yeah I know I said well
what do you think they want me to be
speaker they said well you have to do
what you think's right and so I thought
about it and contemplated and prayed a
little bit and decided to do it
I wrote down two things that Jeanne is
quoted as saying in your book or you say
about her you say she didn't like
politicians at one point and then later
you said not thrilled with your current
job which is speaker well she she wasn't
thrilled when I became speaker it was
just a lot more intense you know I had
been home I work my district every
weekend I didn't have the national
responsibilities that I have today I
didn't have to campaign all over the
country you know almost every week and
then I was home I was home on a Thursday
night or Friday morning and we worked
the weekend and we also oh I had at
least a day or day and a half off at
home and for me going back to the
district and getting my feet on the
ground being with real people going to
the hardware store the grocery store
there's a good way for me to unwind and
I needed to be back home so I wasn't
sure what this job had entailed and how
we'd handle it you in your book you
discussed the differences between you
and Gingrich I have a question for you
when when you retire someday what will
you do will you stay in Washington you
go back home well I don't
in Washington now so I really doubt they
stay in Washington I've thought about
that a lot and I guess that when I'm
ready to retire I'm gonna have to face
up to it but you know I think there's
opportunities out there there's a lot of
things you maybe you'd like to do you
know there's some ambassadorships maybe
I would like to do and I have a great
interest in Japan I have some interest
in Europe but you know that's down the
road I have never set my you know flag
that way that I want to do it and
probably the first time I've ever said
it publicly but so there's some
opportunities in the future that I think
but you know I always said if you do the
job that you're doing now and do it well
you don't have to worry about the next
step and I think I still continue I'm
running for speaker again and lord
willing if that happens and I got
another two years to do my job and we'll
assess things from that point the reason
I ask you is there's so many people who
come to Congress now in the house in
particular do not stay there they go to
the Senate or they go downtown and lobby
right and whether or not that was in
your in your veins you know I you know I
never say never to anything I'm not
gonna run for the Senate I had an
opportunity to run for the Senate
decided I like the house I like what we
do in the house and we get things done
and I think the Senate is not my turf
but you know in a way you bring up an
interesting thing because we're facing
six open seats across the country right
now so in a sense we're a victim of our
own success these people have run
they've been successful and now they're
moving on to other careers we have to
fill those hopes the seats so in a sense
it's something that we have to
constantly keep up with I was struck
when I read your book that so many of
the characters in your book aren't there
anymore and I just wrote them all down
as I was reading about Bob Livingston
Newt Gingrich Dick Armey Bill Paxton
Steve Largent saxby chambliss John
Sununu Lindsey Graham Tom Coburn Susan
Molinari John Kasich Bill's Elif and I
know I've missed some right almost other
than Tom DeLay and a couple of others
the team that you started out with
they're gone
well you know that happens in Congress
today people used to say you know you go
to Congress those people are there
forever term limit or the term of an
issue and all those things that we
talked about you
the average I don't know what the
exactly the average term of a
congressman but it's used to be for a
long time today it's probably eight
years or ten years as average time that
a person stays here and they cycle off
and do something else a lot of those
folks that you mentioned are either in
the Senate or headed for the Senate so I
mean they step up and do other things to
have saxby chambliss and Lindsey Graham
at comers with Colburn's running for the
Senate and others so you know there's
other careers too Tom Coburn did the
show once and it was I think I can say
without exaggerating it wasn't in the
book was a real criticism of the house
and this town did you read the book I
read excerpts for the book if you were
going to criticize your own institution
over there after you've now been there
for how many years I've this is my 18th
year that I've been in a Congress what
would you tell those kids out there in
civics class well you know I always said
yeah I taught a government for 16 years
and I when I okay what first went to the
Illinois General Assembly I said you
know the real difference here is the
difference between theory and practice
that this place is a people business
it's how you treat people it's how you
deal with people is really how you get
things done not necessarily if you're a
great orator if you're a great attorney
or you know a great writer it's how you
can relate to people bring them together
and move them in a direction to get get
real legislation or real things
accomplished and I would say the
probably the most the biggest hindrance
that today that you know this the the
Congress was partisan when I came I saw
the huge difference in partisanship
between the House of Representatives in
the Illinois legislature that I was in
Illinois legislature we were on the
floor together hours and hours and hours
and hours every day and to go through
the process and we weren't in as long so
things were compressed you went across
the aisle you talked to people you
shared a joke with somebody from a story
with somebody from time to time and
there was a collegiality there even
across the aisle you know one of the
things in Congress everybody goes back
to their little own office
they watch a lot of the proceedings on
TV you come to the floor and vote the
people that you do get to know across
the aisle might be people that you serve
on a committee with or from time to time
or have the opportunity to travel with
but there isn't this really cross
cultivation you know cross pollenization
in a sense that you don't really get to
spend time with people I have some good
friends on the other side of the aisle
but they're people that have known for a
long long time and people that I respect
but you know so the incivility that
people talk about in the congress comes
from two things first not spending a lot
of time with people you don't you know
you're off on your your own thing you're
in your office you have constituents you
have you know your whole agenda that
your your staff is driving that you're
busy doing all the time you don't take
enough time to deal with with people on
the floor the second part of that is
when I first came to Congress there were
Democrats over I had a plurality of over
a hundred I think it was a huge floor
allottee and you know I remember stories
about their discipline within their
caucus at that time if somebody didn't
vote with a party or you know didn't go
with Tip O'Neill or didn't go with Jim
Wright they might have lost their
parking place or their locks were
changed in their office or they're lost
at telephone or you know things like
that a little subtle differences and
disciplines that they had that saying
that you know that's a time passed
that's a generation passed and probably
they could get away with that we can't
get away with that I mean we have such a
tight margin that you know sometimes
when I first I was a five vote margin
today we're close to a 10 vote margin
depends on who's here and who's sick but
you have to to deal with your own party
all the time and keep people on board
you know they call them be a speaker but
really they ought to call me the
listener because I spend so much time
listening to people's problems trying to
work through those problems trying to
make change possible for these people
and you have to pull your we're so
closely divided that you have to pull
your team together all the time to get
something done
and you just don't reach across the
aisle it's impossible because they're
pulling their team together all
time to and a partisan basis and you
don't get you know 24 weevils anymore to
come over and cry and vote for a bill
you periodically in this book tell us
how you feel about some other people for
instance you say in the book the Trent
Lott is not a good listener well I mean
Trent I think in his own ways pretty
dynamic leader and he got things done
and he is a golf go to a guy but he
doesn't at least in my experience he
didn't sit down and listen to what you
had say very well I mean you got his
information first
how much listening do you do I do a lot
of listening I I would I watch other
people in government than for instance I
watched Dick Cheney operate Dick Cheney
I'll come in a room is a problem he'll
sit and look over the top of his glasses
and put his you know fingers out his
cheek and listen maybe for 20 or 30 or
maybe minutes or maybe an hour and then
finally say well we need to do this I
kind of do the same thing I that because
I'm copying just my nature but I will
listen to both sides of a story both if
there's two people in conflict or two
committee chairmen that you have to deal
with or a person who wants to have it
has a difficult time to vote for
something and he needs to make sure that
that bill can he can sell that bill back
home or be represented back home and
doing the right thing and so if we have
to make a change in the bill or an
adjustment I'll sit and listen and or
feel somebody feels that they've been
shortchanged by the leadership you know
one way or another the whole spectrum of
leadership I'll sit down there and
listen I have to do that and then try to
solve those problems you call mark
shields and John McLaughlin the two
radio I mean--it always and talk show
hosts loudmouths on television well I
did at one time you know if you watched
John did John doesn't give much credence
to any other person's opinion and
shields is just out in your face all the
time so if you have those interviews you
don't get much time to express you maybe
get banged on but you never really get
to express your opinion or your opinions
never really taken into focus you give
us an insider's view of
what happened around Newt Gingrich and
the attempted coup start that story well
I was whipping as chief deputy whip we
had an appropriations bill on the House
floor and I couldn't find Tom and Tom
DeLay anywhere because we had a problem
we had the coal folks that wanted to
keep coal gasification funds in place
and we there was an amendment out there
for to do away with the fire roads into
the national forests environmentalists
try to do that the people who were
Montana and the Western folks that
needed to keep their forests and try to
keep fires down were fighting that
amendment so I thought that there was a
possibility to tie up an agreement with
the coal people and the forest people to
hold down and they would you know help
each other to feed those amendments but
before I did that I wanted to check with
delay and see that you know that was
okay and that would go along with what
his plan was for the spill what to look
for him couldn't find him and finally
some you know called his office ill he's
not around it's a you know eight or nine
o'clock at night so it's got to be
around someplace
and finally somebody said well he's down
in Paxson's office which it was a
hideaway down on the first floor right
across the hall from word Tom DeLay his
office congressman Bill Paxton or Bill
Paxton to office and the bill was the
chairman of the leadership at that time
so I went down there and kind of knocked
on the door and walked in there having
dinner and boys this kind of both of
these guys were very very close friends
of mine if the conversation just stopped
and I knew that there was something
going on something wrong
and so I I said to attach the time yeah
go go do whatever you want to do which
is natural for time so I did I figured
if they wanted to talk about what they
had to talk about it's fine and so later
that night I got called into a back down
there after we were out of session and
said well you know we have a real
problem there's a group of Young
Conservatives mostly the class of 94 but
a few others that
want to depose Newt they want to vacate
the chair the parliamentary procedure
what are we going to do and you know it
army eventually came into that
discussion and we had a long discussion
into the night delay went over and
talked to those people and it's a story
and the book goes on it really kind of
lays it out what happened well what was
the reason for wanting to oust Newt
Gingrich at that time I think this is in
the eyes of people who I mean it was
that time Colburn's and other folks like
that Lindsey Graham that wasn't living
up to their expectations a lot of those
folks had never really served in a
legislature before and you know they
really I want to say understanding or
didn't accept the compromise that you
have to do to get things done and I
think Newt had a lot of good ideas he
certainly was a revolutionary probably
the most intellectual political mind
that I've ever really dealt with uh
since I've been in in politics I mean
he's always thinking you know he's
trying to think around the been there
over the horizon and I know he's a great
political strategist the dude had a good
idea every five or six minutes and try
to keep up with those things
he moved around a lot of the people want
I think those folks wanted him to stay
on a more conservative bent all the time
and quite frankly some of those times he
Newt had it worked with a again a fairly
narrow majority he had to deal with the
moderates that put him in power but you
show us up close and personal in this
situation that you described that even
in your own party there were people not
telling the truth I mean you you you
suggested Dick Armey wasn't telling the
truth back then well I mean Dick Armey
went into that meeting and said that you
know he understood delay came back and I
think army had the understanding that he
would become speaker if this thing blew
up and you know it was the kind of what
if what do we do who does what and delay
came back from that meeting and said all
these conservatives don't
you a speaker and that really changed
his mind and where he's going to be in
this position and you know I kept saying
let's come back let's talk to Newton the
morning we need to do that eventually
that's what we did Bill Paxton who was
involved in that is now what Lobby he's
lobbying has were in a lobbying firm in
Washington Steve Largent it was involved
in that has runs a telecommunication
Association cellular phone lots of money
yes and then Tom Coburn is running for
the United States Senate right and dick
armey's out work lobbying as well you
were not happy when Dick Armey wrote an
op-ed piece in The Wall Street Journal
but you know dick and I worked pretty
closely together the first four years of
my speakership and I think dick was
somewhat disappointed when Livingston
stepped down and he really didn't get
the nod to be Speaker and I think that's
a personal disappointment we would all
have and he was the next guy in line but
just happened that way and you know one
of the things about speaker anybody if
you have half the votes in your
conference you can get elected to a
party position a conference leadership
position but in order to get elected
Speaker you have to have every one of
almost every one of your people to get
elected that's what happened the newt in
the first place because we had 10 or 12
people maybe 18 people they weren't
gonna vote for him for speaker on the
floor and you can't get elected speaker
it just doesn't happen and I think that
was the realization that dick hand of it
to face up to but you know we worked up
worked together very very closely and I
dick was a good ally of mine and a good
friend I was disappointed when he did
the op-ed piece because he helped us put
together the first Medicare bill that we
passed and the second Medicare bill that
we did one the one we did 106 Congress
the one that we did 107th Congress he
was one of the leaders in helping put it
together and then criticized it in 208
when he wasn't here and I just didn't I
said dick if you're going to do that you
owe me a heads-up before you you know I
think I left him a memo on this phone
and I said you know it's not your
enemies you have to worry about it's
your friends that stabbed you in the
back
as you know they all have access to the
floor even though they're not there
anymore they can go to the gym or go to
the dining room do they come back then
after you had these personal districts
yeah it caught me the next day we had a
good conversation it doesn't but you you
suggest in here that there are times
when the you know you break that bond I
think you told the story about dick a
part and the chaplain and you never were
quite the same again what's the story
you know what a thanks for the first
thing my first became speaker the story
is trust in this place that the only
thing that the only commodity that you
have to sell the only ability for you to
work with people is your word your bond
and trust that people have in you if
people lose that trust then it's very
difficult to get anything done it's
almost impossible to be a leader and my
situation when I first became Speaker I
knew that Newt had a good difficult time
you mean he spent a lot of his time
before he was in leadership you know
bringing down Jim right I mean that was
just the legacy that he inherited that
he you know had and so there were a lot
of Democrats that just didn't like him I
figured when I became Speaker try to
reach across the aisle even in my
acceptance speech I said you know I'm
willing to go halfway in some cases more
than halfway but do you have to go
halfway to and I was willing to reach
across and work a matter of fact when
the chaplain situation when Reverend
Ford decided to retire as chaplain
I broke on tradition because the Speaker
I just made that decision he just did it
and let me ask them Jim Ford had been
chaplain for how many years 20 years and
he retired anyway that's what would have
been what year well it was first year I
was Speaker Boehner minus-20 herself was
probably in 2000 2000 and he came to me
his Sunday I said to me I'd like to
retire well I'd hate to see you go but
you know let me know give me some time
so instead of just making that decision
putting out a search committee myself
making that decision I thought well
let's do this on a bipartisan basis and
so we had seven or eight or nine members
on each side went out and did a search I
think they had 52 candidates some number
like that and I said give me three
candidates without without prejudice
saying just give me three people don't
rank them and then I'll take it to
leadership to Dick Armey
myself and Dick Gephardt will make that
decision and Tom Wiley was the guy that
kind of headed up for me and Tom that
went through and it was interesting
because I kept talking to and I said
well how are you doing and and 52 people
how are you winnowing this thing down
and I remember father's father George
from Georgetown University who was one
of the leading candidates and all of a
sudden out of nowhere kind of out of the
Catholic ranks was this kind of a
undercutting thing that well we can't
have a lobbyist and this guy's a
lobbyist so he won't you know be a good
couldn't be a good chaplain boy there's
some deeds going on here someplace
somebody's got some long knives out and
so the recommendations finally came down
and one of the recommendations was a
fellow that was a Swedish covenant
minister I went to North Park college in
Illinois and Ted van der mean who's one
of my counsel is on the board of North
Park and so you know he was a good
candidate he thought another was Chuck
Wright who worked with the Pennsylvania
legislature and was a Presbyterian
minister did a lot of things here with
the prayer breakfast and prayer groups
on a bipartisan basis matter of fact
Tony from Ohio from Ohio Tony Hall you
know was his nominee Democrat guy put
him forward he had good credentials and
then there was a Tim O'Brien who worked
with for Marquette University and the
people the people program our student
exchange program
perhaps Catholic priest he was the third
guy and matter of fact I had some of my
staffers who actually went through his
program and in effect though Brian was
scheduled wanted to marry one of my
people at one time and so well I we
decided to take all those but when when
Tom
Bliley gave me the list he had ranked
one two three and it's a time I want
this without prejudice I mean just give
me three names I gave him list back to
him and he gave me the same three names
back only on ranked and so we went
through the process and was interesting
because the fellow from the Swedish
covenant how he remember for the fellows
name but he had a good interview but
from my point of view and my impression
it wasn't anything outstanding and the
Tim O'Brien I think was one of the next
guys we had and one in our conversation
and in our interview with him he said
something he said you know I've been a
scholar and work with these kids and
worked around Congress a good deal of my
life he said I would really like to do
this job because I could be the chaplain
I can continue my writing and it was
kind of a red flag that went off in my
mind at that time I said you know I I
don't know if somebody being a chaplain
and working with you know personal
conflicts that people have and doing all
the things that you have to do with
people's own emotional situations around
here but if I want somebody kind of
Chronicle izing this you know putting
this down and writing this thing and
that was kind of a negative to me and
then Chuck Wright came in and a lot of
our members were pushing him Tony Hall
was pushing him and because he had
worked with the prayer breakfast and
some of these groups and I was impressed
by him it he wanted to work with
families he wanted to bring people
together he wanted to do you know almost
like a parish minister or Prairie parish
priest you know work with the people
that he was the only guy that really
emphasized that part of it so in my mind
I thought he was the best choice
I talked to army he kind of thought that
right was the right choice as well
and then I talked to try to get dick to
come in Dick Gephardt to come in and
meet with us and so we could finalize
this it went out week after week after
week and and he was campaigning he was
trying to run for Speaker of the House
at that time and so it was an election
year and so finally I got him on the
phone and I said well let's just make a
decision over the phone as I have these
three candidates down to the fellow who
was a Swedish coven at midnight Jacques
Warwick Devore wore it and then we had
O'Brien and then we had right and I said
dick and I have talked about it we kind
of like right he said well you know I
kind of liked Dvorak he was my choice he
said let me I'm not going to do that
right now let me get back to my people
I'll call you back well a couple days
later he called me back and said well my
people think we ought to go with dick
did that he never made a decision on the
spot he always went back to consular to
his folks people who talked he talked to
and they said they liked O'Brien the
Catholic priest and they said that's
where I'm at on this I said well we got
three to two to three to two one split
on this thing I said taken I want to go
with right he said well you know I'm not
gonna oppose you on it so we all signed
a letter and name right the the chapel
and then things started to come back
Mike Stokke who was my deputy chief of
staff came back to me and said you know
I was just Catholic he said I was at
Mass last Sunday and the priest came
down to me afterward or some dedication
Church it was something he said came to
me after he said no we just had a
meeting of Bishops and this guy was the
Bishop of Peoria and somebody I knew and
had actually played football with in
high school and he said you know there's
a says that hasturs anti-catholic and
that armies had anti-catholic I said
what are you talking about he said well
that's what is happening with these
calls and the bishops meetings I said he
said that's serious stuff
and so all of a sudden there's
anti-catholic things started to build up
well you had a couple people in the
Democrat minority who were unhappy with
a choice and decided this would be in my
opinion would make good political fodder
and really drive a wedge in for this
coming election and so here we are all
of a sudden we have a religious thing
I've never intended never you know I
tried to be open about it and it was a
really a pretty nasty period and an
experience that I had to go through for
the first year that I was speaker and
finally got to the point that looked
like that right couldn't become you know
step in and really serve people as a
chaplain and I decided I just had to go
and and I wasn't going to accept O'Brien
somebody want to come in politically and
write about people's lives and that's my
impression of what he wanted to do and
so he was unacceptable of me so I went
to Father where Cardinal George and in
Chicago a friend of mine and said lookit
I got a problem give me three candidates
and he did and I went and interviewed
him one night in Chicago kind of quietly
and came down and then Coghlan who was
like Vicar of the diocese in Chicago was
impressed me very well I'll never forget
that day we brought him in I introduced
them passed the resolution made him you
know the chaplain and and we went down
to a press conference right off of my
office or right and outside of my office
I'm ceremony office off the floor and of
course all the press were there just
because this is a big issue and they
said first question he said aren't you
walking into a lion's den what do you
think about this job he kind of looked
at me so I said well you know my name is
Daniel and that was the end of it that
was that was the end of it but it was a
nasty time and you know Gebhardt in my
opinion could have helped that and taken
some leadership he knew what the process
was he knew why we made those decisions
but he let this political thing Fester
and I don't think it was good for the
house and I think it was good for the
people's ability to get together by the
way you I was just noticing that you say
in the book and I'm noticing that left
leg is moving right now that worries me
because you say in the book that means
something
I think every time I used to sit on the
bench when I was playing football or or
coaching that leg would go so anyway
that's what does it mean is it mean
there's there's a you're you are you
tensor it when that black I never went
to a psychologist today we have some
videotape I want you to look at it
you're doing something in this videotape
this is from your Reagan speech that you
write about in the book that you don't
like let's roll it and see if you know
what I'm talking about is not a
privilege tonight this honors and
someone I personally look up to can you
tell what I'm talking about my glass no
you say you don't like to read speeches
right right well why were you reading
one there then well this is pretty
important occasion and I think everybody
had prepared remarks pretty formal and
actually the remarks were printed and
for the for everybody distribution but I
I think I am just better off talking off
the top of my head and of course you
have to know a little bit about the top
because the subject I hate to get tied
down to text just them not comfortable
with it some people can bring it off
well but sometimes I can do that too
but I think that that speech probably
turned out all right but you did you
ever write your speeches before you got
to be speaker I never had to give that
many speeches before I was speaker but
in the legislature I always said when I
first ran for the legislature I had two
speeches I had a five minute pep talk
and a 40-minute lecture and you know I
always knew my material and if I wanted
to motivate people I knew what I had to
do I did it
you know the whole my whole life but
giving speeches are just a little
different game why did you write this
book you know I thought there are two
things I want to do first of all I felt
that I had gone through some
extraordinary experiences since I became
speaker came in in the heights of
impeachment there was a lot of
bitterness and in the House of
Representatives people really didn't
trust government weren't
sure about Bill Clinton and then right
after I became Speaker I remember got
called the White House and we were going
to invade Kosovo the next thing that
happened we were in this campaign and
after through the war in Kosovo but in
this campaign and had the hanging Chad
campaign and for a while people said
well you know you're gonna be the next
you're gonna be a temporary president
constitutionally and this thing was hung
up and we couldn't make a decision who
was going to be this the president went
before the Supreme Court and if that got
dragged out back beyond January 20th by
law I would have been president of
States temporarily until this thing got
resolved then we moved the one of the
largest tax reforms and and tax cuts of
American people in American history
right after that right after that we
were September 11th and 2001 we spent
nine weeks I remember in my office
almost every night working together
bringing people together on a bipartisan
basis trying to make sure that writing
the Patriot Act to make sure that we
could pursue terrorists make sure the
airlines would fly and have some ability
to do that make sure that New York was
put back together again make sure that
our defenses in this country our
homeland security was it was better and
that was an incredible time in itself
and then we had the war in Afghanistan
we had the war in Iraq and that kind of
brings us right up to this next election
but there was an incredible six years
and I thought you know it's better to
write this down or to get this thing
down while your memory is still fairly
clear with it and I try to do that and
the second thing I felt actually two
other things I felt you know all my life
I've had somebody kind of help me out
from time to time you know Bob Michael
was a great guy he kind of took me under
his wing when I first came to Congress
kind of mentored me in a sense by
Illinois I had a football coach in high
school that kind of made me realize that
I could do some things I never thought
I could do before and throughout my life
I had some people Tom Ewing when I first
came to the Illinois legislature helped
me out and then I helped him come back
to Congress and you know just good
friendships and people who really helped
you and I think that's important and
I've tried to do that in my own career
is bring people along and make sure that
they have an opportunity even the most
junior members to see you know an
opportunity to move forward and the
second thing that respect you know I've
come from a pretty humble background I
guess you'd say we were had a tough luck
in a small business and change
businesses and we always worked hard and
you know I never got a paycheck until I
was 18 years old and but you always made
do and you worked hard and you did
everything he had to do and partly you
had a responsibility as a family of
working together and whatever success I
had in high school you worked hard and
and you know I never went to an Ivy
League school or never had a lot of
means to do things matter of fact 25
years ago if somebody told me that I
would I was teaching school and coaching
just twenty-five years ago that I had
ever be in Congress let alone to be
Speaker of the House I would have
laughed at him and said you know that's
kind of a crazy idea but you know
ordinary people do have the opportunity
to do extraordinary things if they're
given the opportunity and I think that's
a something that we can't forget about
this country did I read in here that
your original motivation to leave being
a teacher per se was you needed money to
put the kids into college well I was
looking for a little bit better economic
help from the school district if I'm a
side job or whatever else and it was
kind of a story that I always talked
about I went to the superintendent and
said I I'm you know a coach and I'm
working part-time I'm department
chairman I've teaching three or four
topics subjects and I need a little help
how much were you making it well I was
making probably nineteen thousand
dollars a year what year would that have
been
probably 1980 79
so anyway went to him talked to him
about it and he kind of scratched it
says so what's your master do you have a
master's degree is sure so what's the
history of philosophy you looked at me
shakes and shook his head said that's
not going to do anything any good you
know you can't do anything with that and
he said tell you what you go back to
summer school pick up the six or seven
hours and supervision and he had an
opening as a junior high principal and I
might even be an assistant principal in
the junior high was assistant principal
in junior high and he said you know you
can get a better income track the
principal was a good friend of mine in
high school I used to go down there and
he always said seven or eight chairs
sitting out his office areas full of
kids that were you know kicked out of
study hall or talking in English class
or couldn't behave in a bus and he had
to deal with these same kids every day
other side of his office there was
teachers said he had a deal with
teachers problems real problems and to
help him along and I said you know I
don't want to do that for the next
twenty years and there was an opening in
the legislature and so I just kind of so
I'm gonna run for the legislature and I
did and you know everybody kind of made
fun of a wrestling coach runner for
wrestling yeah for the for legislature
that's absurd but I won and spent six
years at it had six great years in the
legislature I was a Republican leader on
revenue Republican leader in
appropriations and rewrote the public
utility Act and the telephone Act in
those six years so I had a great
opportunity people helped me there too
and then I ran for Congress in my little
state rep district I had parts of three
congressional districts two of those
congressmen resigned within three days
of each other after the nomination took
place it was George O'Brien and john
Gropper they both had terminal cancer
and stepped down their nomination so I
thought if I'm ever going to run for
Congress
it better be now and I wasn't even sure
if I was ready so in 86 I ran for
Congress and one came here in 87 1994
you know I was on both the
transportation committee that was on
Energy and Commerce Committee and worked
with Ed Madigan and all these things and
then we took the the leadership and in
1994 in that election 95 I became tea
deputy whip four years later became
Speaker and I said you know life has
come full circle because in my office I
had a beautiful office chandelier I'm a
wrestling coach never thought I'd have
an office of the chandelier and a
beautiful view down the mall in the
national capital but outside of my
office I have these seven or eight
chairs and I got these people I had to
talk with every day and try to solve
problems and people coming in my office
all the time so I'm kind of the
principal this place do I count right
that you're the 51st person to be
Speaker of the House and the Republicans
at one point had a six-year or three
term limit on the speakership those
eight term limit eight yes you still
have it
no matter of fact I'm you know
unsolicited by me they decided to remove
it last year their last a little
Congress and and you have been elected
if you had been the speakership how many
years three beside three terms so it's
six years and there have been a bunch in
the past that have had six years
including Joe Cannon believed I think
Joe was there probably eight years you
got a book on Joe Ken and then you're
right who gave it to you one of the four
former staffers of John Boehner's former
staffer gave it to me he's down at the
White House now but he gave me two books
one book was a book on Joe Keenan and
the other book was just a kind of a
anthology of a lot of difference all the
speakers and the first book I started
going through and looking at all these
speakers that preceded me there was an
older book so it probably didn't have
the last couple speakers in it but all
the speaker's had preceded me it kind of
worked up the ladder they started out as
a lower party official and then became
maybe a assistant conference leader in a
conference leader then up to deputy
weapon and weapon and you know majority
leader and then finally speaker and you
know they were in their late 60s or 70s
or maybe 80s by the time they got to be
speaker they live two years and died
yeah but boy this doesn't have much
future this job but if you go through
the history it's interesting to see it I
want to show you a clip I have explained
afterwards it kind of speaks for itself
but here's Bill Thomas it's been said
that our strengths are our weaknesses
or as my mother would have put it when
they were passing out moderation you
were hiding behind the door
I believe my intensity has served useful
purposes fixing problems and passing
laws that otherwise may not have made it
but when you're charged and entrusted
with responsibilities by you my
colleagues as I have been you deserve
better
moderation is required what were we
watching well this was after a flap that
bill Thomas and the chair of the ranking
member of Ways and Means got into a
conflict you know but he said he said
type of fingerprint any type of thing
there was a altercation in the room and
the Democrats left and a queue fied a
library and we're asking press to come
in and further kind of irritated
mr. Thomas and he called the Capitol
police and did happen they didn't come
and escort him out but it was a
altercation that was about ready to
happen and it came to a situation where
the tension on the House floor
no bill Thomas is a guy who I think is
just a brilliant legislator very smart
man probably one of the smartest guys
along with Bill Newt Gingrich that I
ever worked with this huge intelligence
and has a very intensive drive to get
things done sometimes as he said the
moderation of that guest gets in the way
of accomplishing some things but that
was a very humbling time for bill but we
got it worked out did he change it all
after this well that worked out bill the
bill constantly amazes me
when you were back in as a teacher and I
must say I was a little surprised to
read this and I want you to explain it
you used to have your kids read two
books Upton Sinclair's the jungle and
John Steinbeck's Grapes of Wrath and
when I read I thought it's interesting
that a conservative Republican who
taught would have his kids read those
two books well I hadn't read other books
- I know those two you know those two
books I think we're important because I
wanted kids to understand if you're if
you're teaching history at least to
understand what the culture was like
what the challenges were like you know
people could understand most of our kids
at that time there was still a start
word just up to that point there's a
stockyards in Chicago most of them were
farm kids they took their cattle into
Chicago matter of fact for a lot of kids
when I first started teaching Chicago
meant go into the stockyards didn't mean
going to Chicago
so they could relate to this and but
they couldn't relate to immigration and
all these people come in and so this is
a good book to read about struggle about
how things changed and why society
basically changes and conflict and teach
about change that Grapes of Wrath were
the same thing the dust storms in
Oklahoma and people who had to emigrate
and people who were living on a
shoestring and trying to strive to get
by and the problems they had gave you a
setting for history and you could
explain better explain why presidents
got elected like people you know what
issues work and so I like to use
literature as a backdrop for teaching
history oh that was great you compare
driving a bus a school bus to running
the Congress the United States well I
said run it driving a school bus which I
had to do we were a small school 350
kids if he coached you'd really needed
to drive the school bus because you
gotta take your team's by yourself once
a while but so if you did that you know
on a snowy day or a bad day you always
got that call at 5:30 in the morning
because some driver didn't show up and
would you please run this route but I
always said driving a school bus with a
load of kids on it was like being
Speaker of the House first of all you
had to keep this huge machine or
institution you know going straight down
the road
you had to make sure that all the
charges you had behind you behave
themselves at the same time you had to
look up this huge mirror and watch your
back and I think there's some
similarities the speaker has what
individual powers and you talked a
little bit about the ability to appoint
chairmen you have more votes than the
rest of them explain that well what we
do is a steering committee every year
which appoints chairmen and appoints
other people to certain functions in the
house but that's important and who
chairs really is a you know so many
times chairmanship was just a function
of seniority and the oldest guy standing
who had the most seniority ended up
being the chairman we've tried to look
at that a little different who can best
energize who can best carry out our
policies and get things done and so
we've looked at chairmen we do a
screening process the steering committee
also appoints people to committees so
that's a very powerful thing to be able
to do and I have more votes than
everybody else but you know cumulative
liebelei everybody else had more votes
so again that's kind of a team work as
well with them people who are elected to
the steering committee and then the
leadership that sits on a steering
committee we try to put the best people
and put in place to get the get the job
done what what's gene think of your job
now well matter of fact Gene's retired
from teaching and she's been very
supportive and matter-of-fact you know
my district has changed a little bit
back in Illinois she spends his Jean
loves to golf so she does all the golf
outings we have a deal yeah I'll do the
politics you do the golf outing so she
goes out to all the districts and I run
from the very far western suburbs of
Chicago all over the Mississippi River
so she'll she'll do that she's the vice
president of women's Republican
organization in Kendall County which is
a Mike home County but one of the
smallest counties in the state and they
have 200 and some women in that
organization that's a very viable thing
she is a Garden Club and so she likes
her life I don't think she's ever ready
to come back to Washington
but we don't live in
we live in Illinois what actual city do
you live in a little town called Plano
Illinois which is just about 60 miles
west of Chicago how old are your three
boys I have two boys when one is 26 and
I believe the others twenty-nine just
two children two children and what do
they do well one's going in his final
year law school at Northwestern this
year finally I hope he gets a job
that's Ethan Ethan and my other son
works here in a government consulting
company and when Washington Josh Josh
but you say that government consultants
are really lobbyists well but they like
to be called government whatever right
what kind of a lobbyist is he well I
think he just does general things I keep
arms late we don't talk about what is
what he does he doesn't come to my
office on government so I really don't
follow what he does do you worried all
that he uses your title urine and I
don't think Josh do we have an
understanding just doesn't do that if
you had to go back in that classroom
today on a permanent basis and teach
civics and government what would you
tell them about this job this Congress
the way it works that you didn't know
before well I you know I actually taught
for a little while when I was in a
legislature but just time demands became
so great and you can bring a much more
human view into Congress what practical
and and I would emphasize rather than
you know the mechanics of how a bill
becomes a law and you know everything
that the tenants of the Supreme Court
talk about real thing that's how real
people get things done in this place and
how the dynamics work and that again I
think there's an object lesson that
anybody that has a desire to do
something and discipline to do something
get something done that's always been
kind of my mantra when I was coaching or
in politics and I think that's something
that I would talk about all the time
will the relationship of the money ever
change relationship to the Congress all
the money that's needed and comes from
the businesses and the lobbyists and all
that and you know they'll go back to the
whole discussion and mccain-feingold and
obviously a lot of things have happened
that they didn't anticipate as yeah as
you well know I oppose b'keen
fangled because the tenants that what
they call soft money as opposed to hard
money hard money came from individuals
and pieces at that time of $1,000 or
less soft money came from corporations
didn't go directly to candidates but
went to parties and so what but keen
find of all did was eliminate the soft
money to parties now I feel that parties
are traditional in this country because
if you wanted to help somebody run for
state representative or a state Senate
or somebody in a city council or a
county board you could do that you could
work and help those people today with
the lines between the mccain-feingold
present it's almost impossible to go
campaign for some way that's not in a
national office and you can't even
campaign for president because then you
have to try to meld those two campaigns
it's made it so difficult so it's almost
taken the party out of the ability to
decide who's gonna to build to build
party organizations within a state or in
a county and so what it has is moved it
to these soft money organizations that
aren't really called soft money
organization 527s so a guy like George
Soros for instance who has billions and
millions of dollars can come in and
stick ten or twenty million dollars
nobody knows where that money comes from
whether it comes from foreign sources
there's no track to do it and so you
have a different type of soft money
influence I just think it's wrong and I
think it ought to be repealed I think
there's two things you need to do in
campaign finance reform I've always said
that number one if if people are worried
about the money in the process
then there has to be a transparency and
if you get a $5 check or a $100 check or
a thousand-dollar check from somebody
that ought to go up and who that money
comes from period so there's a
transparency people see within you could
do that with the Internet today within
twenty minutes you can have that on the
Internet the second thing is I think
most the money ought to come from a
person's district at least the majority
of that money so people who elect you
have a say and how this candidate comes
about and
not somebody from outside interest
groups will you move for that yourself
absolutely in the next term I I want to
assess how this election goes I don't
want to say I want to watch this thing
go through one election but I'm ready
prepared to do that any interest in
beating Tip O'Neill record of serving
the longest straight speaker of ten
years
well I think that records sir not
necessarily in this business always set
to be broken I just hope that my tenure
that I can do a good job while I'm there
and when I can't be effective anymore
then it's time to step down and do
something else
where was this picture taken I don't
know this is the book it's Denny Hastert
Speaker of the House of Representatives
thank you very much thanks Brad for a
DVD or a videotape call one eight seven
seven on c-span for a free transcript or
to learn more about book notes visit us
at book notes org next week on booknotes
our guest is Dori McCulloch Lawson
author of austerity letters of great
Americans to their children book notes
can be seen every Sunday on c-span at 8
p.m. Eastern and 8 p.m. Pacific